welcome back you got me there
he used his school's document storage
while drooling into his porridge
storage and porridge you don't get that
on Dateline
once again President Biden finds himself
between a dock and a hard place
that makes me sick inside Riders were up
lately yeah they were
which means it must be time for dogs
keep on slipping slipping slipping to
the wrong viewer foreign
[Music]
I have to point out that that's Gene
singing and Gene doing that and Gene
goes hey I think I did something pretty
good or it's okay you want to take a
look at it it's your best thing ever
James having said that most of his stuff
sucks
all right where am I but this time for
Joe it's his senatorial records back in
2012 then VP Biden arranged to have a
large collection of his documents housed
at the University of Delaware that's a
college cat they're actually on the same
shelf as his award for best plagiarist
at the time he was considering running
for president and by moving the docks to
the school they effectively been hidden
from the press and remained off the
Public's radar until now
that's when we show them yeah just
kidding to date the university still
claims they have yet to organize and
catalog them all but it appears they're
stalling like a one-legged man driving a
stick shift
but why are the documents secret in the
first place what could be in there a
list of the best 10 heads of hair he
sniffed
a recipe for Head and Shoulders flavored
ice cream
that sounds good actually I love that
smell Joe's already proven how careless
he could be with classified docks in his
own home isn't it much of a stretch to
imagine more classified material that
may be lurking in his university in
University collection what does Joe
think about this no no look look I I
take classified documents seriously I
not only take them seriously I take them
to the beach
I take them in my car
I think I'm the University of Delaware
you know why I like classified documents
so much I like the way they smell
pretty pretty
that's two-part question or maybe it's
one part I don't really know is this
worse than Watergate or water polo
I think water polo is worse than
Watergate yeah no one can really watch
water polo seriously what do you put the
cameras no
um all right well now that we've just
established that
I just I I there's been so many of these
that I'm getting kind of confused about
like which how many rounds have there
been now and I spend most of my waking
hours at Fox News headquarters yes so if
I don't know then I feel like a lot of
people have probably lost track uh it's
just very funny and when you put it next
to we're trying to be like we're the
most transparent we're trying to be
transparent we're being transparent as
possible it's like no you're not there's
nothing stopping you from opening this
stuff up to an outside review you don't
need like a transparency Genie to do
that you can just do that I'm curious
too and I also wish that I could
classify stuff that would be awesome
yeah like some like I like you know I I
write things I Journal things I would
like to be like oh that's classified and
if you read or you Snoop my stuff you go
to jail that's very good I would support
that 100 so yeah that's why I'm I'm
maybe I will run for president yes I'm
hundred percent behind in France
Douglas do you get the sense that the
bidens in a way are exactly what they
accuse the trumps of bees and doing
could it be that for like 50 years this
guy has been not been nothing but a
corrupt joke or a clown but he just like
everyone's everyone's kind of giving up
right now aren't they because his cat
says it's hard to keep a track of it it
seems like everyone has documents they
shouldn't have
um when Mike Pence turned out to have
some stuff yeah they like volunteered it
up and it got hardly any coverage
because everyone's like oh just everyone
seems to have done it I'll tell you what
I think is going on here the National
Archives I spoke to a friend who was in
government a little while ago and he
said he thinks this what it is National
Archives have been annoyed for a long
time about people like being too free
with classified documents and they're
putting their foot down now this is the
first time in history we've seen what
happens when Librarians get angry
and they come after you Greg this is
this is what you see a bloodbath total
bloodbath Republicans Democrats no one
survives they're gonna shush the
out of you
uh-oh yeah so Jimmy it kills me that
then I have to always take the immediate
the media side of this which is they
hounded the trumps over their tax
returns yep Tax Returns come out turns
out he wasn't he didn't make any money I
think while he was President there was
nothing there and that goes away and yet
there is no desire for anybody in the
media to actually go there and find out
what's there well the reason they're
done with this story and this is the
reason they hate Biden is he took away
their angle to prosecute Trump and do it
that was the whole their latest sexual
fantasy was Trump and handcuffs because
of classified information right you know
I mean this is if you look at like
PornHub and like Democratic cities
that's the number one search engine is
like Trump and handcuffs but it is
but so the meeting is just done with it
but the people who are still talking
about it are making it worse like the
University of Delaware tried to minimize
the story and made it worse because they
said well we can't release the documents
yet because we're still organizing and
classifying them Yo it was 14 years ago
how many documents does it have that it
took 14 years yeah but then the other
problem is like poor kjp still has to
talk about it and she's just stupid you
know kjp thinks transparent is a man who
has a baby he has no idea
you thought that was funny I thought
that was very good
once in a while it happens do you um you
so you're a lawyer obviously you're a
lawyer where uh what what can we do can
we Sue to see these things can I sue to
see things but that means I might have
to go to Delaware and frankly not sure
you can sue you won't win but you can
try it um I don't suggest you go to
Delaware because he's got a lock on that
entire State I mean he runs that state
like the Corleone family what's the
story yeah he's like bengazara and
Roadhouse man he's got it all locked up
Ben gazara in Roadhouse corleones he's
The Godfather but he made a guy an offer
he can't remember making that's why it's
right
but I mean seriously and and just
fortunately for all of us that's exactly
where the investigation is that a whole
Hunter thing so you know I have great
faith in that now right yeah but at what
point did we all decide did we all vote
on the idea that we were going to turn
America's University system over to Joe
Biden to use as his own personal safe
deposit box you got this thing here
right you got the University of
Pennsylvania which has the Biden Center
which has all that Chinese funny money
you got all the other classified
documents with there I mean what's the
story with that so you can't get any of
that stuff to catch point you can't
foyer that stuff Freedom of Information
Act you're not going to get that from a
college and 14 years to categorize and
and put in one place what his old Maxim
magazines what would a vice presidential
documents like from back then I mean
really he just had melania's wardrobe
yes this guy's got the whole of Delaware
yeah yeah he's really got it locked down
so I'm afraid to drive through that
state he's just got a vault of wigs
but they're adolescent wigs cats he
loves the Adolescent wigs smelling them
are there adolescent wigs I I don't know
it sounds like a punk band lovely all
right I guess we gotta move on